hey everybody this is Sona um you know I
thought it would be a good idea to check
in and I hope you're all staying safe
and distancing yourself socially for one
another I'm having great time let's see
I got a blowout which I realized it was
probably a little irresponsible but I
would have lost 50% of the payment had I
not gone and in my defenses blood as
days and days old I haven't washed my
hair in a really long time uh so I just
moved into my house like a little while
ago my husband and I bought a house and
I know that on sona fixes your life I
once told you guys that my parents
wanted to throw away all my speech
trophies because they thought it was
they were taking up too much space
because I have too many um and I thought
that they did but then my mom gave me
this which is basically a lot of my
childhood is in here and I looked at it
the other day I love what I found on my
speech trophies psdf a spring
championships senior do interpretation
second place but that's fine you know
and then there's this one third place
okay look playing with some good one
where's this one that's all broken
that's first place psdf baseball
championships senior speech ten attained
first place and then there's all these
here's the problem and they're all
broken but the problem is is that when
my mom and dad were holding on to this
I didn't really tear but now that it's
in my house I don't want them so I think
that my mom's idea was they take a photo
shoot with all of these and then just
take a picture to remember all of them
and I I think I'm gonna do that today so
I think today in my home I'm going to
force my poor husband to help me with a
photo shoot with all these and then I'm
gonna throw away what you guys want them
because I don't first place watson
lancer speech tournament first place in
duo oh my god there's just so many
this one is small I don't even know what
this is there's no plaque on it anyway
so I'm gonna take a I'm gonna do a photo
shoot today maybe put on a dress and
some makeup for the first time in a
really long time and yeah we're just
gonna say goodbye to all these trophies
today and then I'm probably gonna go to
sleep at like 9:00 and wake up at noon
because that's right been doing for like
a week all right
I think
I think that's it